all right hello everyone thanks for
sticking around being with us today um
Justin and I are super excited to be
given this talk um so we'll go ahead and
kick things off um by sharing how we use
Python R and shiny um to capture process
and visualize motion um in our focal
system at
ping so if you're familiar at all with
ping um you might think of us as a golf
company but what we really are are an
engineering company that just happens to
make golf clubs um with every product we
ask ourselves how can we use our
knowledge of physics and engineering
principles to improve Golf Club design
and ultimately people's enjoyment of the
game um so the process of making a club
from an idea to manufacturing it to
ultimately putting it in a player's
hands has changed greatly since our
company's Inception almost 60 years ago
um so today we're going to talk a little
bit about how the tools and our Python
and shiny um have made this process more
streamlined um for both our external
consumers and our internal
Engineers so to sort of walk through
this entire workflow um we can give an
example um sort of research question
that we might have such as which golf
shaft is best for a
player so to sort of give a wide
overview um if you're not familiar with
golf um a golf shaft is the component of
the club that connects where a player
grips it at the top of the club to the
club head at the bottom um we typically
characterize them by property called
Flex where on one end of the spectrum we
have like a regular Flex um the
properties here is that it typically
flies higher and is used by players who
swing a little slower um and on the
other end of the spectrum we've got an
extra stiff Flex um it typically flies a
little lower and is used by players who
swing pretty fast those are all sort of
like general knowledge nuggets um but
how do we know if this holds for a
specific player that we're trying to
fit so to give an example of this
concept of flex we have a few pictures
here of our cooworker Chris Chris
happens to be one of the faster swing
speed golfers at ping and he loads the
club with a ton of force in his
downswing so this is after he's taken
the club back from a dress to kind of
the top of his back swing here and as
just as he's getting ready to transition
uh to bring the club down towards impact
now when we give Chris something that's
in our softer Flex or regular Flex
category he's going to create a lot of
deflection so the club the club is going
to flex a lot and when we give Chris
something that's in our extra stiff Flex
category he's going to create very
little deflection now to an extent Chris
is a bit of an outlier in terms of the
general golf population uh with how fast
he's swinging or how much he's loading
the club here but the important thing to
consider is that all golfers load the
shaft and load the club differently at
this point and these loading patterns
should be well understood and measured
to answer the question of which golf
shaft is best for this player so we're
going to Showcase how we utilize our
high-tech motion capture system that we
call focal and leverage posit connect to
answer this
question so focal is probably the most
high-end and in-depth research tool that
we have at ping and it essentially
allows us to track the golfer swing from
the time they address the ball through
that loading phase to just after impact
and we're doing this by tracking some
small reflective markers that we place
along the club head and on the shaft to
model the club as a body as it moves
through space focal is quite a bit
different than some of the other
performance measurements systems in golf
if you've ever watched golf on the
weekends they have the launch monitors
that are kind of tracing the ball flight
and what the ball's doing but with focal
we can actually see exactly how the
golfer manipulated the club and got to
impact and to give some context to the
amount of data that we capture with the
system every swing that we take
generates around 40,000 data points and
that's raw positional data on all those
little markers some velocities and
accelerations of the club head and the
shaft and then even metrics that compare
those two together
and we've had a motion capture system at
ping since 2011 and in the last 12 years
we've had the opportunity to capture
over 75,000 swings on the system and
this data set ranges from tour pro
golfers to Collegiate golfers to Golfers
at ping that are scratch handicap and
golfers at ping that swing a club maybe
once or twice a year all of this data
really helps us drive new product
Innovations and insights that consumers
will see in products in the marketplace
two three and even five years down the
road
now prior to leveraging posit connect
and kind of the shiny framework that
we're using today our workflow was
pretty static and it looked a little bit
like this we would capture data with the
system we'd export that data to a very
flat CSV and we'd store the data in a
super flat table database and then we
would pull down that data in Excel and
do a lot of our analysis on very discret
insights and maybe an AB test scenario
where we're trying to compare one club
and how much it flexs on average to
another club or how fast one Club moved
relative to the other club in that test
and these discret insights are great and
they especially help us when we're
trying to design new clubs but unless
you were one of the key stakeholders
that was really in tune with the motion
capture system it was a little bit
harder for everybody in the company to
access the full swing data kind of that
time series data and Leverage The Power
of of that full swing tracking that
we're getting and we wanted a way to
make this better so today our work flow
with posit connect is much more powerful
it's much more streamlined and it's much
more Dynamic than it has been in the
past and it looks a little bit like this
so again we start by capturing data
we're doing the bulk of our processing
of all that raw positional data in
Python uh those Python scripts are run
directly in the motion capture software
itself and we're using some packages
like open CV to actually spatially map
impact and identify where impact
happened um impact is kind of our key
event to classify a swing there
all of our swing data is then exported
into a Json file format and those files
are then uploaded to our much more
structured relational database that
we're interfacing with via
apis some of those apis go to feed our
physics-based models and from those
physics-based models we're actually able
to directly generate a lot of our
engineering insights what's cool for us
here is that we can take those insights
that we generate and turn them into
plumber apis that feed and power our
consumer facing apps and tools
we're generating a ton of internal
reports via our markdown documents to
give to Engineers on more of a uh test
level or key stakeholders that want to
see certain data points in the lab and
we're heavily leveraging the shiny
dashboard framework that's powered by
things like the Tidy verse and future
and fur to do some cleaning of that time
series data and then also some parallel
processing and Computing of that time
series data to bring it down a lot
quicker and make it very accessible all
of this ultimately leading to that shaft
recommendation for the player
so I'm going to zoom in a little bit on
what one of these shiny dashboards might
look like in the lab and kind of walk
through that
process and what's powerful about the
shiny dashboard framework for us that is
that it allows us to extract these very
Dynamic insights almost immediately
following a swing so we can have a
player come into the lab take a series
of swings and then we can look at things
like where that player hit the ball on
the face of the club and go through some
other impact location Tendencies with
them and then we can pull in that time
series data and talk through where we
see the club bending how we see it
bending where we see it loading the most
and what this means for the player in
their swing and this allows us to take
this really complex positional data and
all these other data points and
translate it in a way that the player
and the coach understand and give them
some of that feedback and we can go
through try several different things in
the lab and open up that feedback loop
to help them take this and and make
action on
it we can further take that player
specific data and compare that player to
maybe a population of player players on
some density charts here and then we can
take that player specific data and
combine it with the insights that we've
generated behind the scenes to
ultimately lead to that shaft
recommendation and what we love about
this is that we're not just
communicating a shaft recommendation to
the player but we're actually able to
use the data to inform the player why we
believe this shaft will help them play
their best on the field on the course
and it's fun to be a part of that and
see how it really takes over in their
game
all right now from a research
perspective um we can take a step back
and look at all of the data that focal
collects going move past that first step
of identifying which shaft produces the
best performance outcome for a player
and move on to the possibly more
complicated analysis as to why um so
does changing the flex of the shaft
meaningfully change how that player
swings or how they Orient the clip face
that
impact and if it does how can we
quantify these changes and use them to
drive our design and fitting
principles so in this we can consider a
sort of recent player tests that we've
run um within our focal system where
players hit two clubs one was a regular
flex shaft and one was an extra stiff F
flex shaft so as Justin mentioned before
um a test like this with 20 players will
generate a massive amount of positional
data for each of the markers on the
clubs we're going to go through that
sort of workflow that he just talked
about and put together a sort of nice
little summary file for some of our
engineers and stakeholders in the test
that include the swing and performance
metrics for every shot for player but
some of our design Engineers that maybe
weren't as heavily involved need
something that's a little easier to
process visually so it helped them see
both a player shotto shot um variation
between the two prototypes as well as a
player-to-player variation within the
test we can utilize shining then the
pait connect um to create an app where
any engineer can go they can select a
test maybe a player or two to compare um
and look at specific metrics so this is
an example of what a dashboard might
look like um as you can see it does
report some like discrete metrics
because our Engineers do care about
these numbers still and they are very
useful to them something that's great
about shiny though is it allows for an
even greater visual effect for that
transient data um so you can see these
are two different players that were in
that test and we can produce these
graphs using um the tools available in
packages like GG highlight and G giraffe
um this gives Engineers Insight on how a
player reacts to the glub within the
time frame of the Swing um so something
in golf that's really cool is that
regardless of a player's skill level um
everyone's swing is very unique and
different um so these two players that
we have um graphed here are both very
highly skilled but we can see that both
the magnitude um the maximum resultant
shaft flection that we see and the time
that it occurs in the swing are very
different um so this sort of information
being able to visualize the focal data
in this manner is really nice for our
engineers and me allows them to easily
determine like where they should focus
their research and development efforts
so this sort of initial analysis and
visualization is great for a specific
test the results of a single test um but
what if we want to use this data in the
future or look at the results of many
tests that's where our steps in um and
provides a sort of statistical framework
um that we need to analyze 10 15 20
years worth of player testing data um So
within this we can see patterns emerge
from prototype to prototype or patterns
emerge out of specific player groups
that we're testing so kind of continuing
our example from the shaft test and we
want to run a basic statistical analysis
we can run an SPM test on those two
players here the gray section represents
a sort of significant difference that we
see and so what we can get out of this
is that there's they're very different
throughout the entire swing except for a
period kind of you know in the middle
part of their downswing and then at
impact so there's no statistical
difference um or significant difference
between the two shafts at impact this is
a really important finding for our
Engineers additionally we can use the
tools available and the dev tools
package to create our own um packages
within ping um for all the physics based
modeling and simulation that we do for
Club golf ball impact and golf ball
flight and then using these packages in
conjunction with all of our historical
testing data allows us to conduct
virtual player tests where we can
simulate how players will react to and
perform with clubs without having to
physically prototype them or run any
tests this is great for us and saves us
time and money
so now sort of covered our complete
workflow with focal um from capturing
and processing um every data point with
our cameras going through Python and
then producing consumer and internal
facing apps with r and shiny the
combination of all of these programs
with posit um has really allowed our
company to streamline our research and
development process and make it very
smooth so thank you for attending um
we're Happ to be here and take any
questions
all right people in the crowd are asking
the hard-hitting questions can you help
them break
90 we'll do our best we will come see us
in Phoenix good um and on your databases
what kind of databases are you guys
using for this
workflow that's a great question our um
we've got a software engineer that's
built um a database with more of our is
team I'm actually not involved with our
is group um but I that we have two or
three people that have built some pretty
extensive databases for us awesome do
you know at least if like there are
Cloud databases they are Cloud yeah very
cool you guys have any other questions
um it is
P.I
sl- CD um happy to take any more
questions uh we've got a few more
minutes
yeah what's your
question
so the question is um so everyone in the
back in here is well how do you sync the
time between those swings um to make
sure you're kind of starting at the same
point so the data that gets taken out of
focal and process through python we can
then take that into R and marks specific
times in the swing so one a couple of
the times that we Mark are when they
start the downswing and when they hit
the ball at impact so those you know
depending on how fast a player swings
the amount of time that passes through
that um time frame will be different um
and so we can Mark you know a start
position and end position and then look
at the relative time difference and so
then what those charts showed were the
relative so like the percentage of the
swing that has been completed between
those two points if that makes sense and
all that's done in
R awesome thank you so much can we give
him another hand for our
[Applause]
speakers